un soulagement pour cette centaine de
fidèles venus prier ici pour cette messe
en plein air place vauban un
rassemblement religieux pour revendiquer
leur droit de culte le conseil d'état a
donné trois jours au gouvernement pour
revoir le décret limitant à 30 personnes
le nombre de fidèles autorisés à
assister aux cérémonies religieuses et
les associations catholiques estime
qu'il s'agit d'une mesure non nécessaire
disproportionnée surtout discriminatoire
la plupart des fidèles qui étaient ici
se sentent tout simplement exclus de
leur église
une colère un qui dure depuis le début
du confinement et le conseil d'état
rappelle d'ailleurs que la liberté de
culte qui comprend la liberté de
participer collectivement à des
cérémonies fait partie des libertés
fondamentales
chose qu'a rappelée à notre micro hugues
de la cause de m référé pour cette
mobilisation religieuse en extérieur je
suis saisi par des gens qui m'expose un
problème de droit et je constate assez
vite que il ya enfin ça m'apparaît en
tout cas une violation d'une liberté
fondamentale qu'est la liberté de
manifester il ya aussi une violation de
la liberté de religion ont considéré qu'
il fallait absolument contestées chat on
avait les moyens de droit pour le compte
est jeté et d'ailleurs les juges ont
fini par nous donner raison
c'est parce que la liberté de religion
est une liberté fondamentale ce qui veut
dire qu'elle est placée au dessus des
autres libertés que le conseil d'état
peut être saisir en référé liberté quand
les requérants estiment qu'il ya un
texte qui porte atteinte à cette liberté
la belge en a qui a tenu cet office en
extérieur se dit à lui aussi a satisfait
de voir que le conseil d'état leur donne
raison
il était aussi heureux de voir autant de
fidèles venus à s'être réunis ici place
vauban
malgré le froid est la fois continuer
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus important
selon lui écouter vous attendez
effectivement à skis et beaucoup de
monde et c'est ce qui est arrivé parce
que eh bien justement tout le monde
réclame jette mais c'est donc le fait
qu'elle soit en plein air ça donne une
facilité plus 20 plus grandes à tous de
venir puisque en plus en plein air
dehors on n'est pas venus voir les
jolies pas là dix ans donc je suis très
heureux qu'ils aient autant de monde ce
soir c'est une manière de manifester
bien que
les catholiques et français ont encore à
la fois vivre au coeur et qu'ils sont
toujours prêts à tous les combats
finalement même s'il fait froid et et
nuit on est toujours là une messe en
plein air significatif du mal être que
ressentent la plupart des catholiques en
france
et finalement ils contestent avec leur
arme principale c'est-à-dire la foi et
la prière afin de se faire entendre du
gouvernement